let's speak to the health secretary
sergey javid thank you for coming in uh
health secretary
um
how many cases of omicron do we know of
in the uk
we've got two confirmed cases uh at this
point in time
and
and what we've done is that everyone
will know because the decisions that
we've made over the summer the success
of our booster program we've made huge
progress against this
against covet 19 and no one wants to see
that put at risk and that is why the
moment we learned about omicron and the
potential threat it poses we didn't
hesitate to act we've taken swift action
in i think in a proportionate way
because the strategy of this is to to
buy time to give our scientists time to
assess uh this variant because there's
still a lot of significant uncertainty
but also to put in place some mitigants
uh against the potential threat so that
is why on thursday i set out the six
countries we're adding to the travel red
list from southern africa we added four
more yesterday anyone arriving from
those countries will now have to hotel
quarantine and then yesterday when we
had these the two confirmed cases one in
essex the other in nottingham we sent
out further actions and and those are
you know very quickly we're requiring
that anyone that arrives from abroad
wherever they are coming from to
self-isolate until they get a negative
pcr test result we are also requiring
that if anyone is a close contact of
someone that is suspected to have this
new variant then they will be asked to
self-isolate for 10 days we will be
requiring face masks and shops and
public transport and the other thing
that still remains hugely important but
i think it's fair to say now now more
important than it was before is our
vaccination program we know that
vaccines work yes this new variant they
may make it less effective or not but
the vaccines work they are our first
form of defense and that is why i've
also asked our expert advisors on
vaccines called jcvi to give me very
quick advice on broadening boosting our
booster program and i expect to get that
advice imminently and this is this is
all about you're acting swiftly in a
proportion and balanced way to protect
the progress that we have made you are
still placing a big bet on the success
of the vaccination program and that's um
that's clear let's talk a bit about some
of the
the add-ons that the prime minister
talked about yesterday and starting with
the return of these the masks um
they're compulsory on london transport
um but the evening standard and
other surveys tell us that
in truth we've now got to a place where
many of the millions who take the tube
every day for example just don't wear
them and anybody who experiences that i
i take it pretty much every day
will know that
it really the discipline isn't there the
tfl transport volunteers tell us that
just 108 people
of those millions have been removed from
the underground for not wearing a mask i
mean how are you going to enforce this
new ban well first i'd say trevor i
think that over the last few days and of
course this has been very fast moving i
think people would have been able to see
the and understand the concerns around
this new variant and they will be
concerned perhaps not just for
themselves their friends and family and
want to know that the government is
taking proportion action so i think that
will encourage people in any way to to
listen uh and think about uh some of the
new measures and take them very
seriously and by i think doing it in
this proportionate way where it's for
public transport it's for retail outlets
i think it's the the right level of
response on masks and it will be by
government regulation
and that means that i think people will
take it seriously but my point is
everybody in london knows that it is
mandatory to wear a mask but
by my reckoning and i've been testing
out this week about a third of people
completely ignore it and nobody
throws them off the tube just 108 people
in the last three or four months have
been
taken off the taken off transport
because they weren't wearing a mask how
are you going to make this well this is
this is this is really about protecting
the progress uh that we have made and
now you said i get that
you said in your estimation about a
third of people don't wear it you've
done that this week but i would
i would think that you probably haven't
been taking those soundings since people
have begun to understand more about this
new variant and and why the government
has thought that these new measures are
appropriate so i do think people will
take this more seriously and i think
that will apply to public transport it
will apply in shops it will be a
regulation as it has been before but
it's important i think to to act in a
proportionate way and also in a
temporary way i hope this is
something that we can remove within
within weeks but i do think in terms of
making progress we want life to to go
back towards normal but
at this point in time given what we know
about this variant and the the the
expert advice uh that uh has been
received i think it is right to take
some proportion and balanced actions
okay i get that the idea of yesterday's
announcement was if you like to shock
people into realizing that we're in a
new situation but wouldn't it have made
more sense to do something
a bit more dramatic
in terms of actually instructing
changes in behavior so for example we've
we've um
there's no social distancing man new
mandate there's no masks in pubs there's
no working from home requirement
last week when we spoke um
you i i said that you were adopting a
risky strategy by not being a bit
tougher this week
i know that what you're saying
may feel like resolved to you but i
think to some people it may just feel
like okay they're waving a flag but in
truth nothing much has changed
well i think that let's first turn to
those other types of measures that we've
had in the past and you've just talked
again about whether it's work from home
or other social distancing measures
we know now that those measures those
type of measures they do carry a very
heavy price
they you both economically uh socially
in terms of non-covered your
health outcomes such as your impact on
mental health for example
so if one was to make decisions like
that they'd have to be
done very very carefully and we're not
there yet we're nowhere near that and
and the reason is because we just got to
step back and take a proportionate and
balanced response and what we have done
by first of all you're targeting travel
from those countries where we know that
there's a particular risk from this
variant uh secondly by asking people all
travelers to to take a a test and and
wait for a negative result i think that
is proportionate and what we've said on
face mask and also boosting the booster
program now i'm still waiting for final
advice on that but focusing on the
vaccinations and these other measures i
think this is the right response now of
course there will be people out there of
course that will say that why didn't you
do this and why didn't you do that the
the job of government is to look at the
facts that we have and uh and and make a
decision that is proportional and
balanced and that's exactly what we have
the secretary what you want to do you
should already told me that says shock
people into realizing how serious this
is
your critics will say what you describe
as proportionate and balanced feels like
complacent
in this job you have critics you know
coming from uh every corner and so that
that is uh not something that i think
that should drive government policy what
we should be driven by is
the facts and as i say quite openly that
with this new variant there's a lot that
we don't know about it and that is why
we need to buy some time to assess it
and and learn more and as we learn more
we can respond appropriately one of the
things that we do know about this is
that we don't understand whether uh the
vaccines that we currently have will uh
stop it um
isn't that another piece of evidence
that really you're taking this a bit too
lightly
no not at all i think what we do know at
this point is that
there's given the number of mutations in
this new variant there's reason to to
think that it may be and i stress the
word may that this variant may turn out
to make our vaccines less effective it
may not we just don't know enough but
but as a as a
precautionary measure you know what we
are doing these measures but also
turning to the vaccination program even
if this variant turns out and it's an if
even if it turns out to make vaccines
less effective it might be a small
impact it may not but the point is that
the vaccines are still going to give you
more protection than otherwise and that
is why the booster program is so
important we've done over 17 million
boosts now in the across the uk i think
some 36 of the population over the age
of 12 that's more than any other country
in europe and it remains a vital part of
our defense and and please can i just
say to any one of your viewers you if
you're eligible for a vaccine whether
it's your first dose your second dose
but certainly your boosted those please
play your part and take up that offer of
a vaccine when this all started the
prime minister became very fond of
saying i'm gonna level with you um
is it time to level with us and uh
come clear come clean about this it's
going to be like this every winter now
isn't it with new variants new
possibilities we're going to run out of
greek letters
is this the future
um i i don't think so i mean i think
that will there be more variance i think
there will be almost certainly
especially when most of the world is not
vaccinated against this sadly and that
is something i think every country needs
to step up and do more we're playing our
part but we need more countries to play
their part but we will have to learn to
live with covid we will never defeat it
we have to learn to live with it we have
to learn to live with it as we have
learned to live with flu of course it is
not flu and
you know we need to you learn more about
it and but we have many more measures
and tools in the box today that we
didn't have
even this time last year the vaccines
the antivirals we understand more about
it so we will learn to live with this
but at this time just given the
emergence of this new variant and what
we do know about it i think it is right
to respond in this way
um i haven't got time during this
interview to list the number of times
we've been reassured and then things
turned round
we had to do something a bit more
we have to have a few more restrictions
um
what are we going to see by christmas
time can you reassure us can you
guarantee
that we are going to be able to see
our families our loved ones we're going
to be still going to be able to travel
at christmas time well you asked me for
guarantees and i think it's fair to say
that the nature of this pandemic is that
it would be irresponsible to to make
guarantees but what i can tell you is
that the actions that we've taken these
proportions and balanced actions
will buy us time it will give us the
those precious weeks certainly that our
scientists need to assess this variant
and uh as for yes about christmas i
think people should continue with their
plans as normal for christmas i think
it's gonna be a great christmas
it is um
not that inspiring when the prime
minister says oh it'll be better than
last year last year was pretty
drab uh let just get one thing at least
clear when are the new rules going to be
coming in
the uh
the face well the red listing has
already happened the face mask rules
are planned to come in on tuesday the
measures around the border we have
always i think rightly taken a full
nation approach across the uk and so
we're working with our partners in the
uk and we will bring them in as soon as
possible um i talked to professor barry
shubert from south africa uh the the
their chief government advisor
he was very cross
at uh the way that his country and
others in south south africa have been
treated by
us and other rich countries
uh we're not distributing the vaccine
and by the way on top of that adding
insult to injury we're stopping
traveling um
have we gone over the top
no i think the response has been the the
right one is a balanced response but i
will also say i think south africa has
acted in an exemplary way it's a it's a
great partner of the uk on uncovered in
many other
issues uh i think it has done absolutely
the right thing to share the information
it has with the world in much the same
way the uk did when alpha when you
remember the alpha variant and we yeah
we shared everything we had with the
rest of the world because we wanted help
and south africa has taken a a similar
approach and they've done the right
thing all right let's talk about the
other
horrid news this week
deaths in the channel um let's not go
over the detail of that but what we're
going to do about it was it a
misjudgment on the part of the prime
minister to publish his letter
to the french president
no it wasn't and i'll explain why but
first can i say this is what has
happened is absolutely tragic this
terrible loss of life and i think it's
just a a reminder to everyone whether
it's in the uk in france that we all
need to be doing what we can to break
the business model of these people
smugglers they are ultimately
responsible for this and that does mean
of course working closely with our
friend france and i think the what the
prime minister set out in his letter uh
the the sort of five points of action
whether it's on joint patrols or
intelligence sharing these these issues
i think they are all the right issues
and we should be working together on
them
you uh
as a government are basically saying
that you have to stop these boats
if you can't be sure who's in these in
these boats um
what is the actual policy here do you
want to stop these boats crossing or is
it uh
the case that what you want to do is to
make sure that people are safe i mean
what what's the actual policy that
you're adopting because it doesn't seem
to be clear
what you're really trying to do here i
think our policy is very clear and that
is wha these boats must stop the people
smugglers are taking advantage of these
very vulnerable people from poor parts
of the world misleading them sticking
them in these you know the sometimes you
can't even call them boats and putting
their lives in danger this is a criminal
enterprise and for that reason it must
stop now of course we can't just do it
on our own we do need the cooperation of
the french and again you asked me about
the pm's letter and i think what the pm
has set out those are exactly the kind
of things that we need to do and i hope
the the french will will take that and
work with us
but if if the point is to save these
people's lives why isn't the government
focusing more on
more legitimate routes for refugees
rather than uh putting people in a
situation where okay they may be legal
but they're going to do this shouldn't
shouldn't you be focusing on making sure
that they have more legitimate routes by
which they can prove or not prove their
asylum status and so great question and
that is exactly what the government does
in fact the uk should be very proud of
the sanctions
actually since 2015 i think we have
resettled the uk through um through the
refugee programs we've resettled over 25
000 people more than any other country
in europe when i was home secretary i
expanded those programs uh pretty patel
has also expanded those programs we
should be very proud on the on the big
offer we make to people that are in
conflict zones and elsewhere uh to to
come to safety just as we've done in the
last few months with with afghan
arrivals is absolutely the right thing
to do the wrong thing to do is to let
these small boats and let these criminal
enterprises your profit from these
people and and put these lives in danger
we will never tolerate that and it is
right that we do everything we can to
prevent it i understand the words but
let's look at the numbers
they are going up and up and up since
you are home secretary they've gone from
a couple of thousand a year to
eight to ten thousand a year and now
this year it'll be upwards of 25 000.
whatever you say you're doing the
reality is more and more people are
coming uh coming in through this route
risking their lives as well as uh
creating illegal landings you haven't
got enough offshore base uh through
which to process them you haven't got a
relationship with the french i mean
pretty patel doesn't even get invited to
meetings anymore the french won't have
them back
what is your plan to solve this well i
think that the home secretary is doing a
lot so for example the the as you just
said she it's a thing we have to do in
cooperation with others and she doesn't
even get involved invited to the
discussion to solve it
part of it of course is about
cooperation and that is a big important
part of it part of it is things that we
can do domestically so the nationality
and borders bill that we have in front
of parliament now uh will make this
you're dealing with this challenge uh
you're easier than it is today it will
mean that you know for example that if
you are if you are someone that comes
from a safe country like france and then
somehow gets to the uk and then claims
asylum that we will you first understand
that you're more likely to have been an
economic migrant because otherwise you
would have claimed asylum in the first
safe country you are in and and i think
it is important to have these these
changes
in law and so these measures are being
taken forward but at the same time you
know whatever we can do we still need to
have uh cooperation with our french
friends and i think reaching out to them
and and suggesting your proactive
suggestions around whether it's joint
patrolling uh whether it's a returns
agreement i think these are all the
right things to do um look i'm not
making a stupid pun here but there is
some sense that the government is a bit
adrift at sea here this week
prime minister lost his place in a big
speech
he sung the praises of a cartoon pig
he saw his majority cut from 80 to
26 on one of your key policies social
care and he triggered a diplomatic role
with the french when we absolutely as
you've just been telling me need their
cooperation
uh do you still think boris johnson is
an election winner
yes absolutely and let me tell you why
because we are delivering on our
promises in the same of that same time
frame you just talked about we have set
out a an investment fraud of 96 billion
pounds in rail the biggest this country
has ever seen absolutely transformative
we are taken
took through parliament the biggest
reform to social care ever with the most
generous means-testing capping costs
ever that something that all governments
of the past have tried to avoid and this
government is taking on head-on
delivering on our promise and when it
comes again where we started our
conversation today when it comes to
dealing with this pandemic we have made
huge progress hospitalizations have been
falling in recent weeks we are making
huge progress we have the most
successful booster program in europe so
i think the the this is a government
that delivers on its promises and deals
with the challenges they face so to all
those grumbling conservative black
benchers who are saying oh maybe it's
time for the prime minister to uh start
his next career you're saying he's going
to be here and he will lead us into the
next election yes
health secretary thank you very much
indeed thank you